la realidad que nos encontramos en el
terreno un día después de que el
ministro de defensa ruso dijera que esa
pausa operativa del ejército de su país
en la región del dumbas se acababa es
totalmente diferente a esa retórica que
viene de las grandes capitales o de los
burócratas la realidad aquí según nos
dice quien defienden estas posiciones es
que sigue siendo un infierno como lo ha
sido desde el principio estamos en una
ruta que conduce hasta la población de
ciberes que se ha convertido en el
frente de batalla después de que la Gran
Vía de la vida como la llamaban en ese
momento entre
en control de las fuerzas rusas aquí en
este momento los soldados ucranianos y
las diferentes fuerzas defienden sus
posiciones Pero ellos son atacados
constantemente por la artillería y dicen
que la situación no ha cambiado en
absoluto especialmente durante esos días
que supuestamente las fuerzas rusas
estaban de parón aquí se teme que El
Avance sea ahora no solamente hacia la
población que es totalmente atacada
permanentemente Si no hace las
poblaciones de eslovians y que serían
los próximos grandes objetivos de las
fuerzas de Moscú